[Music]
have I told you I love you yes dad you
told me like a billion times honey
you please come down here
. as long as happen you can't go in
there I lost my family I failed to
protect them I'm sorry doctor Kersey
nothing yet so there's nothing that I
can do is that what you're saying
gonna have faith have faith work out for
them
if a man really wants to protect what's
his
he has to do is for himself the men who
did it are out there we're gonna hunt
them down one by one you're not gonna
kill me no
Jacky's
take me back you got a cartons from
crossfire yeah you said next time an ink
will be in the lake
you are gonna be all right I promise
[Applause]
[Music]
everybody's watching this viral video is
this dude right foot taking the law into
his own hand
you'd be a hero keep smiling but is it
wrong you're cocked locked and ready to
work
I'll say someone took my wife everyone
involved is going to pay
you look much better getting out
socializing mm not so much
well whatever you're doing keep it up
okay I will
[Music]